time to get
cooking with nanny bubbe today she is
showing us how to make
a delicious beet salad welcome back
nanny bubbe i cannot wait to hear this
it sounds perfect for the summer time
doesn't it really but i've got it i've
got to tell you there's
tremendous feedback right now anyway
there is
um it is very i'm so sorry i'm hearing
myself come back into my own ears and
i'm losing my thoughts so i apologize
so let me just tell you that uh i had a
beet salad
in laguna beach and it was absolutely
amazing
and i absolutely wanted to do it but
beets seem so daunting to me they seem
like ecommerce
and it seems like you can actually like
cutting through the skin or cutting
through the meat is very very difficult
but i found out after this salad it was
so delicious
i really worked hard to figure out a
great recipe
and so here it is so the first thing i
want to tell you is to separate your red
beets from your golden beets it's very
important
and what i'm going to show you is as you
cut it off it starts bleeding
all over everything so you always want a
piece put a piece of parchment
underneath it
and you always want to do your golden
beets before your red beets
and because if you don't see what
happens you will get your golden beets
pink
so we're going to slice off the ends we
are going
to shave off the skin and one of the
most important things to tell you
is that if you put the entire bulb
into the pot to steam it will
automatically
make the outer part of the bulb very
very overdone and the inner part under
done
so you really want to dice it and or
slice it before you put it into the
steaming pot
and so i'm just going to show you really
quickly that we're going to dice it
whoop
dicing it here slicing and then some
dicing real fast
and into the pot into the silicone
steaming basket so i'll just take a
handful
and just show you it goes right in like
that
and then each piece will be perfectly
perfectly steamed
so the next step we're going to do is
we're going to be making whipped
rogue now two things about rope bird
roguefort comes
directly from roguefort france it france
it cannot say rope for just like you
can't say champagne unless it comes from
champagne france
also it is a sheep's cheese it's not a
cow's milk cheese so if you're allergic
to cow's milk you
you can eat it which is great so we've
got
room temperature roquefort into the food
processor
about two tablespoons of marscapone
cheese
we're going to take a squeeze of lemon
juice
and a tablespoon of olive oil
into the pot do you like roquefort
mercedes
i'm contemplating all of this i love
that and i love it
okay this salad is only 10 ingredients
it sounds so extravagant
and we got this good for you yes it's
beautiful
thank you i can't wait to try this so
what you want to do is you want to
refrigerate this for about three
30 minutes to get a little bit hard
which i've already done
and i'm going to show you how to plate
this so the first thing we're going to
do
is we're going to take the arugula we
put a little bit of olive oil and lemon
juice onto the arugula already
so we're going to put a mound of it just
like that now you can either platter
plate this or individual plate it last
night for my husband's birthday i
individually plated it and we're going
to take a mound of the red
first right this red will go on the
bottom
just like this 10 ingredients good for
you
i was i never thought to count that but
that was a good call on your part i love
that
but it's easy yes
and not not all food needs to be easy
because
sometimes easy isn't as healthy as you
would want so now you put your golden
beets right on top are you loving that
on top of that we are going to put
pistachio nuts
just like this you see that now
one of the other keys is taking a little
bit of french sea salt boy everything is
french i bet
even beets would be french but they're
not i think they're russian originated
in russia
a little bit of french sea salt and now
the beet dust this is the key a
tablespoon of sugar
a teaspoon of beet powder
and it's just this little fairy dust
that you sprinkle
all over including on the side of the
plate
and then very quickly off with the
cheese
a little bit over here and a little bit
over here
which i almost forgot here we go
and just a little bit of beef powder on
those because it turns a little bit gray
and the beet powder brings it back to
blue
and there you have it you love that
beautiful summer salad i had no idea
that beet powder was a thing and like we
said
10 ingredients nanny bubbe you always
have
the best recipes that looks delicious
you can't be beat
at that thank you you can't be beat
check out danny bubby's kitchen and
garden on social media and online at
nannybubby.com
thank you to chapman automotive for
sponsoring the segment las vegas now
we'll be right back